demi lovato is a 10 out of 10
on the happy scale because she just got
engaged
i'm really excited on wednesday the
singer shared the exciting news that her
boyfriend
max eric put a ring on it and guys
it's huge
demi shared these sweet engagement snaps
on the beach in malibu
just moments after her man popped the
question gushing in the caption quote
i knew i loved you the moment i met you
it was something i can't describe to
anyone who hasn't experienced it
firsthand
but luckily you did too i'm feeling
great i'm very excited
the 27 year old entertainer added that
she's never felt
so unconditionally loved by someone in
her whole
life i'm not crying you're crying
oh thank you no but seriously i'm
definitely crying because demi brought
on all the damn feels adding that max
makes her want to be the best
version of herself quote i'm honored to
accept your hand in marriage
i love you more than a caption could
express but i'm ecstatic to start a
family and life with you
i love you forever my baby my partner
here's to our future
max also shared some pics of the special
moment including
this shot of that bling an estimated
eight to ten carat emerald cut diamond
which could cost between 450 and
thousand dollars like i said
huge the 29 year old actor wrote in part
quote i cannot spend another second of
my time here on earth
without the miracle of having you as my
wife
here's to forever baby demi hit up the
comments writing
yay let's get married baby it's amazing
earlier this year
rumors that the two were dating swirled
for weeks especially after demi
accidentally crashed max's instalive
[Music]
they finally confirmed their romance in
may appearing together in ariana grande
and justin bieber's stuck with you music
video
since then the two have been pretty damn
cute on social media
last month the former disney channel
star gave max a sweet shout out on his
birthday
writing being with you makes life so
much fun